[Music]
Zachery sneaky Scuderi is one of the
most prolific ad carry's in the history
of league of legends so much pressure
put on cloud nine they lose to GA he's a
fixture in the cloud nine ball and
somebody who is always performing on the
rift the kind of workhorse you wants to
build the team around look at the wards
on the bottom side here for fox they
pretty much know they can just keep
going Arcadia it's over who's sneaky
back to the other side every sub has
been use the shrine on sneaky from
smoothy as well they are holding each
other dearly behind the turret in the
offseason he is consistently one of the
most highly viewed League of Legends
twitch streamers and his unique brand of
memory has become ubiquitous around
North American League fans
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah and over the course of the last
year he has also become one of the most
famous cosplayers on the Internet
[Music]
in August 2016 sneaky twitch chat
reached a donation goal that ssam dress
up in a schoolgirl outfit and the
Internet can of worms that opened up was
more than anyone could have expected
sneaky continued to set up more donation
goals for more outfits after the success
of his first schoolgirl stream he
escalated from schoolgirl to a maid
courtesy of a fan and eventually to a
parody of league of legends skins with
star guardian forgot coffe blank has
become an integral part of gaming
culture over the past decade cosplayers
go to extreme lengths and are to
perfectly mimic the appearances weapons
and accessories of their favorite
characters the community has grown into
not only a way to celebrate passion for
games but also a celebration of personal
expression and some cosplayers are so
beloved that they're even flown out to
events it's from this community that
Sneaky learned the tricks of the cosplay
trade his girlfriend Esther Lin is a
successful cosplayer who helps Nicki
take his cosplay skills for the next 11
Sneaky's initial outfits garnered a lot
of attention for his twitch stream but
the one that really transcended his
stream and broke the Internet was his
elementalist Lux cosplay
hello in front of almost 32,000 viewers
sneaky became more than just an NA LCS
all-star almost overnight his cosplay
went from a small part of his stream as
popularity to a household topic among
gamers and a topic that rather
surprisingly those gamers loved the
unanimous life I think it definitely
brings in a whole new audience for sure
there's a lot of people that like say on
the Twitter like I don't follow you for
any of the league stuff I'm just here
for the cosplay am i oh okay so it's
stuffy pretty cool and yeah I think it
is pretty well received among even the
people that we're currently following me
maybe it's turn some people away but it
definitely brought a lot more
professional gaming has always towed a
fine line between content creation and
performance products the digital nature
of the career path allows players to not
only shine on stage but also build them
up as something greater outside of the
game this is something that Sneaky has
had success with through his twitch
stream and social media following but
his focus on cosplay and serious cosplay
is something that's unprecedented he's
continued to set patreon and donation
goals in order to fund increasingly
elaborate outfits notably Sneaky has
chosen to cosplay mostly female
presenting champions this kind of a
gender bending cross-play has a long
been a fixture of the cosplay community
and Sneaky is just the latest in a long
line of cosplayers who are working to
break down the stereotypes around gender
every time the makeup Sun they put on
the whole off I'm like who am i I just I
don't really recognize myself because
all the makeup and the work done to like
make me look different is really
surprising and alright I think I look
really good in it and it's really cool
to see and with each jump into the next
outrageous outfit of another popular
League of Legends character he's gotten
better and better sometimes we've
requested like a specific one so one
that might not necessarily be sold as
often which means we have to get someone
to make it for us and then all the
makeup
and that takes like hour and a half two
hours honestly it takes forever and then
actually putting it on the costume is
like 30 minutes till like 45 so the
whole process takes forever
he went from elementalist deluxe to
Pizza Delivery sivir to star guardian
Soraka and most recently a scantily clad
pool party re as of the time we made
this video
sneaky has around 1,500 patron
subscribing to his cosplay patreon page
with a minimum donation of $2 per month
and a maximum donation of 50 that would
sneaky on paste to make a minimum of
thirty eight thousand four hundred US
dollars a year just as a cosplayer all
while maintaining a pro career including
a historic run at the World
Championships of cloud9
not bad for a 24 year old sneaky of
cosplay Fame even stretched all the way
to South Korea where it reached then SKT
ad carry bang Bang's out on stream that
if he and sneaky were both voted into
all-stars the duo would cosplay Ziya and
pecan and after the fans delivered so
did two of the world's greatest ad
carry's though there was a little bit of
confusion over who would dress up as
work on a new duo never-before-seen we
got saya and bless the sticking what the
best part to go with saya another's diet
know there's bias
you're not bad for someone who doesn't
work on what's more is that sneaky has
been able to handle this without any
controversy he's become more than just a
professional ad carry more than just a
professional streamer more than just a
professional cosplayer he's added an
access to his personal brand that
crosses lines that many of his peers
have never even toed sneaky is showing
us the good side of gaming communities a
universal unconditional love for the
games they play and for the players who
share that love with them
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]